[Applaudissements]
mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues ma question s'adresse à
Madame la Ministre chargée des PME du
Commerce de l'Artisanat et du Tourisme à
l'heure de la sobriété énergétique nous
devons faire de la lutte contre tous les
types de gaspillage une priorité je me
réjouis que votre ministère est ainsi
pris à bras le corps le sujet
extrêmement important du gaspillage
alimentaire
le décret paru au Journal officiel ce 18
novembre relatif aux modalités de
l'information des consommateurs sur le
caractère consommable des denrées
alimentaires en témoignent en effet
selon l'ADEME le sujet concerne près de
10 millions de tonnes de nourriture
consommables jetés chaque année en
France les nombreuses initiatives prises
depuis des années n'ont pu mettre fin à
ce gaspillage qui reste inacceptable car
une grande partie de ces aliments reste
consommables après l'expiration de la
DDM la date de durabilité minimale
il convient donc d'informer les
consommateurs sur la signification de
cette inscription et de rassurer sur les
enjeux de santé qu'ils peuvent soulever
et qui sont bien légitimes
la loi AGEC votée par notre assemblée en
2020 et soutenu par les députés du
groupe démocrates prévoyaient des
dispositions qui allaient en ce sens et
que votre décret vient concrétiser
c'est normalement le cas de la mention
supplémentaire qui pourra désormais
accompagner la DDM
nous avons de ce point de vue un
important travail de pédagogie à faire
auprès des consommateurs notamment pour
lever les craintes en matière de risque
pour la santé madame la ministre
pouvez-vous nous dire ce que
concrètement se décrivent à changer et
quels efforts qu'on déployé le
gouvernement auprès des industriels d'un
côté et des consommateurs de l'autre
pour que cette mesure puisse contribuer
réellement à changer nos pratiques je
vous remercie je vous remercie